who's up next who's up next hello oh my
god
oh my god
he looks more like you than you do
that's where you're here when yeah
that's not what's your name uh matt
now
have you have you made yourself look
like matt smith uh no i think i was born
this way
yeah it's a tragedy is it yeah
okay
and where where do you live matt bristol
in bristol yes so close to cardiff yes
do you have a do you have a question
from outside yes i do in the children
need clip that was shown um david
tennant wears the fez i was wondering if
any more hats were involved in the
episode and did you get the fez on john
hurt
sorry matt
sorry buddy
if you stood face to face it would look
like a vase
i mean he does look very like you don't
thank you very much have you seen him
before
no no
who's up next who's up next oh
oh
okay one more one more hi oh hello
what's your name sir stefan stefan and
where are you from los angeles and have
you flown in for this we yeah i did
actually i've been um flying around the
world not to outdo the girl earlier but
i've been working on a doctor who tattoo
and um and i've been having all the
doctors to actually sign my arm and have
it tattooed over the ideas to get them
all oh crush um actually since we're
talking about it wait wait wait hang on
myself
you you sorry i just signed your arm at
comic-con yeah i i ambushed you in a
hotel lobby yeah and i was pissed and i
said careful cause i was drunk
and you actually did it
where's matt i did yeah matt's right
here and then uh sylvester mccoy is here
and peter davidson and i'm actually
missing david
oh
we actually figured in a spot
specifically for you to sign okay oh all
right what's your name again stefan okay
stephan quickly someone will show you
how to get into the studio run in quick
quick quick
quickly leave your jacket jacket so uh
tell him about leona maybe he could sign
it somewhere else oh yes they did we've
seen that
we've got we've had a lady why did we
have a man i've got a pen
i'm just saying okay hello stefan hi
come on in now uh this is david tennant
hey this is a good opening thank you
again hi it's an incredible outfit where
did you get all this stuff um this was
actually from debenhams i was lucky
enough
so why did you go in here yeah that was
that was actually made special
specifically for you mr jimmy carr wants
to ask you a question what do you think
it's going to be like to touch a girl
i don't want to go over the lines though
okay
i'm kind of nervous yeah
beautifully done thank you thank you
david uh
by the way can you sink no no i can't at
all